ces membres portent des chapeaux à
plumes et de longues tauges rouges on va
en parler ce soir oui coup de projecteur
à présent Aurélien sur la commanderie
des vins d'Amboise une des nombreuses
confrériies que compte notre territoire
créé en 1967 elle fait partie d'un
folklore qui pourrait s'éteindre si de
nouveaux membres plus jeunes ne la
rejoignent pas romain Delville a suivi
ses membres lors d'une sortie c'était le
weekend dernier dans les rues
d'Amboise
sur la vingtaine de confrériies que
compte l'indrire la commanderie des
grands vins d'emboise est reconnaissable
à sa tenue inspirée de celle des moines
hospitaliers qui vivaient sur l'île d'or
au 12e siècle tandis que la coiffe
rappelle François 1er quant au crédau de
la Commanderie il est clair on se doit
de défendre Parmont et PARVEAU la vigne
et le vin du territoire d'Amboise ça
c'est c'est c'est anayable et ça lors de
l'intronisation on le jure alors
l'occasion d'un chapitre comme celui-ci
samedi dans les rues d'Amboise d'autres
confréries ou associations patrimoniales
sont invité les amboisiens dis Loire les
confréries du Nouga de tour le poellon
Tourangeau ou encore les talmeliers du
Bonpain de Touren ont dépêché des
émissaires moi je la je la représente
théoriquement on est plusieurs mais
comme il y a beaucoup d'invitations à
travers la France donc tous les membres
de la confrériie sont éparpillés un
petit peu partout pour représenter un
peu le la profession chocolat à la
Commanderie des grands vin d'Amboise il
y a une vingtaine de membres qu'on
appelle des dignitaires Jean-Marie
blerry en est le porte-drapeau rentré en
1984 l'assureur apprécie l'ambiance avec
les copains dignitaires pour l'instant
on a beaucoup de chance parce que on a
quand même malgré toutes ces années
passées on a toujours cette communauté
entre nous c'est c'est super on fait
rentrer certains nouveaux dignitaires
pour justement renouveler et c'est là le
grand défi pour les années à venir
renouveler les dignitaires pour faire
perdurer le folklore des
[Musique]
confréries